good evening and welcome to tucker
carlson tonight just moments ago Brett
Kavanaugh was formally sworn in the
Supreme Court of the United States
it happened in Washington and it
happened as you know after a full month
of very bitter debate he was the
president at the White House ceremony
just minutes ago on behalf of our nation
I want to apologize to Brett and the
entire Cavanaugh family for the terrible
pain and suffering you have been forced
to endure those who step forward to
serve our country deserve a fair and
dignified evaluation not a campaign of
political and personal destruction based
on lies and deception what happened to
the Cavanaugh family violates every
notion of fairness decency and due
process our country a man or a woman
must always be presumed innocent unless
and until proven guilty with that I must
state that you sir under historic
scrutiny were proven innocent thank you
a remarkable moment you wouldn't think
our leaders would need to publicly
defend the presumption of innocence and
that it would be controversial when they
do but that's where we are politically
of course this whole thing turned out to
be an unexpected debacle from Democrats
the lessons of their defeat are pretty
clear creepy porn lawyers make bad
national spokesman screaming mobs of
child activists scare normal people who
are watching at home wild allegations of
gang rape tend to be counterproductive
in other words it is in fact possible to
go too far and they did it's not a
complicated message and yet none of it
seems obvious tonight to Democrats the
activists left has learned an entirely
different set of lessons from the
Cavanaugh experience the Supreme Court
is a sham the Constitution is
meaningless the Electoral College must
go only a country divided into warring
tribes can be ruled
effectively if we can't control it let's
burn it down that is the message they've
internalized watch our activist gathered
at the Supreme Court and reacted after
the calf not vote on Saturday afternoon
keep in mind as you watch this this is
not a clip from a zombie movie it's
Washington DC 2018
[Applause]
the children of affluence raging and the
rage continue to on cable news and on
social media we've got to eliminate the
electoral college they chirped in unison
white men are bad well the message was
obviously coordinated important media
figures seem to be saying exactly the
same things at exactly the same time and
indeed they were they were repeating
talking points from the Democratic Party
whose interest they faithfully serve for
generations conservatives called this
the liberal media but that's not quite
right these are not liberals they're not
people who believe in free speech or
transparency or due process or
challenging corporate power or any other
recognizable liberal value these are
party people
they are hacks and joiners and drones
they read the latest pronouncement from
the Central Committee like their
Scripture they repeat whatever they are
told they are robots liberals used to
defend the rights of the minority and
good for them watch now as Hillary
Clinton explains how entire states
should lose their political power
because voters don't agree with the
majority of rich kids in Brooklyn watch
this do you think the electoral college
should be abolished I said that in 2000
after what happened to the 2000 election
with Al Gore that an anachronism that
was designed for another time
it no longer works if we've moved toward
one-person one-vote I think it needs to
be eliminated I'd like to see us move
beyond it yes it isn't just the
electoral college either in the past few
days many have been saying the Senate
itself should be changed with different
states having a different number of
senators all of a sudden everybody on
the Left seems to be saying things like
this including supposedly unbiased
reporters
shut up Wyoming nobody cares what you
think that's the new message from the
party that pretends to care about the
powerless but then the left has ever
been big on self-awareness here's one
especially amazing example of that this
is an onion piece waiting to be written
it comes from Tom Steyer he's a finance
billionaire who is one of the Democratic
Party's biggest donors people listen to
Tom Styer only because he sends them
money
and yet Stiers latest crusade is against
and we want to prepare you now for a
blast of hot irony rich entitled white
men watch this and savor it
a group of very rich very entitled white
men wanted to tell the rest of the
country we are going to have our way and
if you don't like it that is too darn
bad yeah that's what Tom Stiers against
people like himself who behave like he
does let us know when you stop
snickering and then think about what Tom
Styer is saying here he's saying Brett
Kavanaugh is not on the Supreme Court
because the majority of the US Senate
voted for him as the Constitution
prescribes what's actually happening
says Tom Steyer is that Cavanaugh was
installed by a specific racial group in
order to hurt and disempower every other
racial group in America this is tribal
warfare posing as democracy and your
tribe is losing that's what Tom Steyer
is telling you now as a factual matter
this is insane it's the kind of lunacy
that would have gotten you booted off a
cable channel five years ago it's also a
lie
and is dangerous it's exactly the kind
of thing that Hutu leaders in Rwanda
were saying in the early 1990s
responsible people do not talk like this
and yet suddenly it is everywhere on the
left and not just among the professional
wackos pounding on the front door of the
Supreme Court the line between dangerous
extremists and US senator is blurring
all of a sudden on the Left Watch noted
race hater Linda Sarsour explained who
works for us on the inside please give
it up to the senator from the greatest
state in the United States of America my
state New York senator Kirsten
Gillibrand
imagine a clan leader introducing a
Republican senator to public event this
way one of our people who works for us
on the inside that's the equivalent of
what you just saw
sour sewers embrace of Gillibrand
they've got basically no media coverage
it's normal now the press just applauded
it how far can this go we'll spend an
hour watching other channels and see
what you think here for example is a guy
with a Harvard Law degree over on MSNBC
explaining how Trump voters are actually
Nazis watch Trump has delivered for
these people on the things that they
care about most he has delivered racism
for these people he has delivered
misogyny for these people and now he's
delivered the Supreme Court for these
people we're gonna see if this if this
reign that they now have control over
all three branches of government we're
gonna see if this rain lasts for 30 days
or two years or thousand-year Reich all
the other people in the panel not oh
yeah that's right a thousand-year Reich
keep in mind that hundreds of thousands
of American men died to stop the
thousand-year Reich and an awful lot of
their children and grandchildren grew up
in this country to vote for Donald Trump
only to be called Nazis for doing it not
that mr. Harvard Law School knows any of
that he probably couldn't tell you the
year the Second World War ended he
doesn't care history means nothing to
revolutionaries and that's why they keep
repeating it